a pressure moment for posh dine book the
Chancellor's social democrat challenger
it would be the final parliamentary
faceoff with Angela Merkel before the
upcoming elections Mackel pushed her
conservative coalition's economic record
with less new debt and lower taxes dick
Coonan Vytas we can do both we have
eased the burden on families and
businesses we've invested in educational
research and we put the brakes on public
debt fast I'm book was picked to dispute
that claim digas f-stop germany's
national debt has risen by 400 billion
during this legislative term the point
is you don't know how to handle money
katom game Angela Merkel batted back the
accusation she said the opposition
lacked ideas and their only solution was
to raise taxes z 1 i'm gonna be
presented with the highest tax income in
the history of the federal republic all
you can think about is placing more
burdens on the very people who drive our
economy that's your policy budge time
book had one last parting shot focus my
diesel aghia we've already heard this
policy statement three or four times
over that's also why half of the
government bencher completely
overwhelmed with the desire to sleep see
good in on the gloves are off from now
until polling day on sep tember 22nd the
battle for votes will be driving German
politics